what's up guys bang bang this past week
saw tons of chaos and uncertainty in the
traditional Financial system and also of
course Bitcoin responding as well first
let's start with the Federal Reserve the
FED is in control and the old adage
don't fight the FED is as true today as
it's ever been the FED hiked interest
rates by 0.25 that is the ninth straight
interest rate hike over the last year or
so
over the last year we have seen the FED
dump about a trillion dollars off their
balance sheet and they've hiked interest
rates to five percent but even though
they continue to create Tighter and
Tighter Financial conditions the
official inflation metric has not
dropped below six percent that causes
major issues because every economic data
point is Pretty much telling the FED to
continue to create tighter Financial
conditions continue to hike interest
rates and continue to conduct
quantitative tightening but while they
do that the banks are in crisis we have
seen multiple banks in the United States
from silvergate Silicon Valley Bank
Signature Bank and First Republic Bank
all come under massive stress and have
to be bailed out either by the
government or by the private Market but
that banking crisis is not just here in
the United States we also have seen the
virus spread into Europe First Credit
Suisse was a victim and eventually was
sold off and also all bondholders were
wiped out but now Deutsche Banks seeing
their credit default swaps drastically
increase in price which signals that
there may be trouble ahead for one of
Europe's largest banks now as we look at
what's going to be the solution the
government is stepping in both here in
the United States and abroad we saw the
Swiss National Bank step in and provide
liquidity to Credit Suisse but now
Deutsche Bank may need the same
back domestically the Federal Reserve
the FDIC and other organizations are
throwing monetary Bazookas at these
Banks we have seen them step in with
both the FED discount window and also
the federal program for Bank lending
that was recently set up
the banks are pulling hundreds of
billions of dollars of liquidity from
these programs and on top of that we've
seen the fed's balance sheet increase by
about 400 billion dollars in the last
two weeks to put that 400 billion dollar
increase on the fed's balance sheet into
perspective the FED has given back about
64 percent of all progress they made in
quantitative tightening over the last
year there are stairs on the way down
but there's an elevator on the way up
when it comes to the fed's balance sheet
now as the FED continues to step in and
provide more liquidity and they continue
to increase their balance sheet you can
think of what's going on as the FED has
one foot on the brake and the other foot
on the gas and they're confusing the car
because while they continue to raise
interest rates they're providing all
that liquidity and the market doesn't
exactly know what to do but the market
is looking at those interest rate
increases as something that will be a
thing of the past in short order the
market is pricing in multiple interest
rate Cuts before the end of 2023 which
would be a full-on pivot back to loose
monetary policy both quantitative easing
and a drop in interest rates coming from
the Federal Reserve
now as this occurs we are seeing two
impacts that relate to bitcoin the first
is there is a psychological Awakening
that's occurring in the Bitcoin World
more and more people are realizing that
their money sitting inside some of these
Banks may not be as safe as they
previously thought they have questions
about the debt in the United States
which the debt to GDP ratio increased
from about 62 percent back in 2007 all
the way up to 129 today
if the debt to GDP ratio in the United
States has doubled since the last
financial crisis we must remember that
we are weaker when we get into this new
crisis and so naturally people start to
question what are the Alternatives
Bitcoin is one of those Solutions and we
have seen Bitcoin come flying out to
start the year up about 60 or so but
there are other Alternatives that people
will turn to including gold real estate
and others I personally prefer Bitcoin
but to each their own now one of the key
components of the current financial
crisis that's worth calling out which
will have a positive impact for Bitcoin
is that the deposits that are fleeing
these Banks causing all this stress is
not just coming from Bank runs yes the
bank runs do have a negative impact but
also many investors are merely moving
their US dollar deposits into money
market funds and other types of assets
where they can generate a higher yield
whether people are moving deposit money
because they want to withdraw from the
bank or they simply are moving it into
non-deposit accounts it puts the banks
under stress anytime you see swap lines
between the major Global central banks
all being used heavily it tells you that
people are under stress and the central
banks want to make sure that they try to
prevent and mitigate any future risk But
ultimately you have a choice to make you
can keep 100 of your wealth and economic
value concentrated in a system that
appears to be on a rocky surface or you
can choose to diversify as we know
Warren Buffett Charlie Munger and many
other great investors diversification
sometimes can be an increase in
resilience on top of that we will
continue to see a younger generation
choose the trust software over a
human-led system the fact that going
into this week no one knew what the
monetary policy of the global Reserve
currency would be it's quite shocking
that is something that feels Antiquated
and probably something that will change
over time
ultimately the banking crisis I do
believe will be solved I do not believe
that the U.S government the Federal
Reserve the FDIC the OCC and other
organizations will allow the banks to
fail that is also true internationally
as well but in order to prevent that
failure to prevent this banking crisis
from getting worse there is going to
have to be a hell of an effort where
they are going to provide tons and tons
of liquidity into the market that
liquidity is likely to be inflationary
and it is likely to increase asset
prices as we look at Global liquidity
coming from those major central banks
and it continues to increase across the
world asset prices tend to do well
simple supply and demand economics if
there's more demand meaning there's more
dollars in the market seeking a home
asset prices tend to Trend upwards now
you have to remember unless you're a day
trader the day-to-day movements of this
stuff probably doesn't matter as much
but we continue to see an extension a
long-term trend of the way the system is
set up we have a fractional Reserve
banking system we have a debt-based
economy and as debt continues to
increase as the banks continue to
leverage that fractional Reserve System
assets like Bitcoin over a really long
time frame will probably be big winners
continue to watch what's happening in
the current banking crisis continue to
watch what the Central Bank responses
continue to watch what's happening in
Europe and other parts of the world but
ultimately I think people and what we
see on chain is that the people who just
dollar cost average into great assets
and hold them for a long time tend to do
well that's exactly what's happening
with Bitcoin wallet addresses with 10
Bitcoin or less continues to hit
all-time highs and that just means that
millions of people around the world
they're simply bitcoining and chilling
that's it for this week I hope you
enjoyed this update and I'll talk to all
of you next Saturday